le pont wilson à tours qui supportaient
jusqu'à présent une partie du trafic de
la nationale 10 le pont wilson s'est
effondré aujourd'hui dimanche une
troisième piles du pont wilson s'est
enfoncé cet après midi à 16 heures
le pont est maintenant détruits sur plus
de 70 m un reportage de jean pierre
gauthier et un commentaire de jean paul
fleury 9h ce matin à tours sur le pont
wilson un des trois ouvrages qui dans la
ville enjambe la loire peu de
circulation encore soudain les pêcheurs
et les passants aux alentours entendu un
grondement sourd une des arches du pont
est tout simplement en train de
s'affaisser en entraînant une partie du
tage il s'agit calme en cette partie du
pont descendre un petit peu évidemment
je n'ai pas vu tomber l'autre partie que
je ne pouvais pas voir mais j'ai vu les
pierres dégringolé dans l'eau et j'ai vu
une voiture qui désespérément faisait
crisser ses pneus et or là c'était
vraiment pathétique parce qu'on vit la
voiture qui tente grimpe elle était
littéralement sur un mur en face d'un
mur
et puis tout d'un coup on a senti les
pneus qui a éclaté puis elle et elle a
réussi à monter et s'était terminée le
type est parti à toute allure à une
personne n'aurait vu des des voitures
qu'on met dans l'eau en fin de compte
nous on était certain que non parce que
bon ben on n'a pas vu deux voitures
montées à flot avant de s'effondrer
définitivement et on était convaincu que
c'était la seule voiture qui descendent
point ce moment là et on va il avait pu
s'en sortir
il semble donc bien que l'accident n'est
pas fait de victime
quant aux raisons de l'effondrement on
avait de tout d'abord penser à une
explosion due au gaz mais d'après les
premières constatations il s'agirait
plutôt de l'enfoncement du nh d14 piles
du pont dans le lit de la loire sans
doute sous l'effet des dernières crues
la pile qui s'est enfoncé avait déjà été
bombardée durant la dernière guerre et
reconstruite par la suite vers 16h cet
après midi une autre ping s'est
effondrée entraînant dans sa chute une
cinquantaine de mètres de chaussée
supplémentaires actuellement trois des
arches du pont wilson sont détruites et
les pierres continuent à se détacher du
tablier outre l'interruption de la
circulation l'accident a entraîné la
rupture des canalisations d'eau de gaz
et des réseaux électriques et
téléphoniques qui desservent le centre
et le nord de la ville
heureusement la situation a pu être
rapidement reprise en main et seul
l'alimentation en eau semble encore posé
quelques problèmes actuels
[Musique]